some pretty awful images have come out I
mean we could do this literally I could
do eight clips on this every week but
some more awful images came out of what
Isis is doing in Iraq and in Syria and
this time it involves the gays surprise
surprise so we've got a couple images
for you here let's take a look so this
is Isis throwing gay men to death or at
least men that are accused of being gay
in Nineveh Iraq so they're literally
just publicly executing them by throwing
them off the roofs of buildings and this
has happened before this is just a
couple pictures of it the third photo
that we've got here this is two men were
charged with thievery and bound to
crucifixes victims are commonly
crucified sometimes after they've been
killed in Isis public executions by the
way I should mention that are our allies
Saudi Arabia does stuff similar to this
and what you're looking at right now is
Isis stoning a woman to death for
allegedly committing adultery all right
so we've done a whole bunch on this and
it just sort of never seems to stop as
Jen mentioned in the earlier segment
they've got two Japanese hostages right
now that they're threatening to behead
unless Japan gives them two hundred
million dollars should any of this
surprise us at this point what actually
before I even ask you that shouldn't the
gays be in an uproar right now why why
haven't I heard HRC or GLAAD or you know
when when Russia was doing this we're
not even going this far but when Russia
was Russia it was that they were having
vodka that supposedly did not support
again you know by the way that Stoli
vodka which was made in labs on the show
when we were actually wait a minute it's
not even made in Russia yeah that's the
if you can support something like I'm
not gonna drink you're certain brand of
vodka or I'm gonna boycott your Olympics
that's a lot more it seems I got my
Ratan jabo goal than this overwhelming
seemingly endless stream of violence
coming from this region I mean to go up
against a country that we're going to
engage in the Olympics with is very
different than engaging with countries
that are throwing people off of
buildings for being gay I just think it
seems so hard and so difficult so what
you can't wrap your head around at like
is this real life right so when Isis
gets in the Olympics then we'll figure
out how to deal with them properly and
what would we boycott of Isis is they'll
end up making their
no but I think that's a good point that
it seems like such an overwhelming
daunting task there's no way to even
cook like in ten country ten Muslim
countries right now you can be killed
just for being gay like that's actually
law like they're not breaking any laws
right there so like when you're trying
to take on institutionally multiple
countries I don't know that the HRC like
I can do anything right right I don't
know that they can do anything it just
seemed odd to me that you never hear
GLAAD saying anything about this or HRC
hey they're gonna go oh your whole
country not only does it believe and you
know in in very anti-gay policies such
as I don't know killing people for being
gay and stoning women to death but it's
just everything on a whole level it's
nice well they'll cut up your hand for
stealing so I think that you think well
I'm not even gonna touch that if I'm
glad because where do you even begin you
feel like you're talking to a sect of
people that are just barbaric and not
reasonable and what do they give a [ __ ]
of GLAAD issues a press I know I would
be more for us I think God who of course
it would be more for us they're not
gonna go oh [ __ ] you know things that
they feel like they can actually change
so if there's a policy in the United
States or in a country that we are
actually actively doing business with it
is worth their time because you can
actually enact change and see something
happen where if you're wasting your time
in that section of the world where the
the world leaders of all the major
countries can't even figure out what to
do I think GLAAD is like let's deal with
stuff it but we can actually I think
there's it goes back to the point that
you brought up which is like why aren't
there more people coming from that part
of the world to sort of be a little bit
apologetic for it Yeah right like
watching it there they just threw
something out for building to a crowd of
people that are just watching there's
nobody in the crowd surrounding it where
they're saying it's like thrown off the
roof too so they there's an inherent
problem there like I think there are
probably plenty of people especially
ones that at least have internet access
that want to do something but they're
standing out there in the crowd but guys
guys please don't throw the gay guy off
the roof well then next thing you know
you got thrown off the roof - yeah well
they the power numbers a little crowd
could just turn their back and simply
not watch I understand that's not
happening right I'm saying the way you
have to enact change there on the ground
is not again through issuing a press
release through some organization in the
United States who condemns you because
over there it's chill to throw someone
off a roof for being good yeah that's a
whole mentality ship that's not going to
change just through complaining or bored
and then as you were saying there's no
product to boycott they're not even
trying to salvato or host some sort of
international sporting position too much
about glad I was doing that do you think
we have some like real like cognitive
disconnect between like how we live and
what's going on in the rest of the world
because no matter how many of these
stories we do and no matter how many
times you see it it's seriously hard to
believe that this I mean I think I have
a disconnect like 500 miles inland right
like I've never lived anywhere up the
coast so I guess far be it for me to say
that like I can even identify with
someone in the Bible Belt right you
can't let a little Allah let alone this
I can't get out of it yeah yeah I think
there's a complete cognitivism accompli
Tlaxcala sweer more connected than we've
ever been we have the ability to see
stuff that's happening in real time
across the world and that's a very
recent development so like we will see I
think we will see people you know the
Arab Spring was the start of it people
actually rising up against whatever that
they thought was was wrong and I think
we will start to see this once people
are introduced to to other cultures
right like this is what the the tenets
of the Peace Corps was created on right
we kind of be created the Peace Corps
there were three tenets of it one was
you know go and help this far-off
culture the second was you know maybe
teach them something about American
culture and teach them about you and the
third and what he always thought was
most important was bring that story back
and try and create empathy here because
you experienced something that none of
your friends and family have yeah to him
that was always the most important so to
that point you know I give America a lot
of [ __ ] and the whole reason I'm doing
the show is I want this country to be
better but I've started to think in the
last like two months or so as these
videos constantly come out and as we see
all the stuff that's going on in Europe
and free speech and xenophobia and the
headings and everything that's happening
all over the lace that maybe we need to
take a little moment to realize that
things are actually pretty good here not
to say we have we've got racial problems
we got problems with bullies we got
economic right every day we get it we
get it we talk all about that what do
you think we don't as Americans like
just take a moment to be like you know
what it's actually pretty good first
world problems and those are like third
world problems where your basic human
rights are vile
and not even consider forget violated
they're not you don't even you don't
even have any basic human rights let
alone civil rights yet the higher-level
rights exactly they don't really have
that so I understand it it's okay to
address first world problems you know if
you're having the trouble with your
cable company provider it's all relevant
so it's not like you're like oh well I
don't want heat or I don't want access
to whatever it is you feel like
everybody to access because there's
beheadings in other countries and people
getting thrown off stuff but it does
yeah you go wow we do comparatively have
it yeah have you been feeling something
similar to that yeah absolutely I mean I
think that any opportunity you have to
sort of get outside of yourself and
realize how fortunate you are you take
that right like whether that's
volunteering or whether that's traveling
or whether that's you know even just
like going down to skid row right and
and taking a walk around anything that
makes you realize how how fortunate you
are is a positive but but in the case of
I mean in the case of this I think it's
so it's a tough right I think that you
have to you have to just look on the
side of like compassion and peace always
and I'm like the hippie and me is like
come on like that's not bomb anyone and
let's not do anything let's just like
travel and experience this and see what
happens from that human connection when
you've met someone you're less likely to
go bomb them right when you've met
someone you're less likely to bomb them
there you go